linda moltenhau is an investigative
journalist and an award-winning
documentary filmmaker particularly
lauded for her early coverage of the
taboo topic of cattle mutilations click
on the time stamp in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro my name is
kirchey mungle i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the underrived nature of
reality the constitutional laws that
govern it provided those laws exist at
all and are even noble to us if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging with
others on the topics of psychology
consciousness physics etc the channel's
themes then do consider going to the
discord and the subreddit which are
linked in the description there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kirchheim uncle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support now with regard
to sponsors there are three the first
sponsor is short form short form is a
place to go if you don't have the time
or the inclination to read an entire
book yet you want to get the gist of it
so that you can be conversant as if
you've read it i mean that in an
extremely positive sense and you'll hear
more about short form toward the middle
of the podcast the second sponsor is
brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge
uncertainty what i loved is that despite
knowing the formula for entropy which is
essentially hammered into you as an
undergraduate it seems like it comes
down from the sky arbitrarily and with
brilliance for the first time i was able
to see how the formula for entropy which
you're seeing right now is actually
extremely natural and it'd be strange to
define it in any other manner there are
plenty of courses and you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model is predicated on u1 cross
su 2 cross su three those are lead
groups continuously groups visit
brilliant.org slash toe t-o-e to get 20
off an annual subscription and i
recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
now comprehend subjects you previously
had a difficult time grocking the third
sponsor is algo now algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce return and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by amjad hussein who's been a
huge supporter of this podcast since
near its inception in fact amjad has his
own podcast on ai and consciousness and
business growth and if you'd like to
support the tow podcast then visit the
link in the description to see amjad's
podcast because subscribing to him or at
least visiting supports the toe podcast
indirectly thank you and enjoy
hi linda how are you
hi kurt i also heard that it was
i also heard you turn 45 yesterday so
happy birthday
80 revolutions around the sun
my brother and i were celebrating in
santa fe and we had a wonderful time and
i am so grateful because the number
doesn't mean anything to me i've never
felt stronger oh great i have ever had
more energy
feeling that i am so close
to being alive when the headline hits
that we're not alone in this universe
it's it's preposterous that that still
is the superimposed
we'll say
government sanction point of view
so it is
interesting to me
that at this point that
my vitality and energy for doing 18-hour
days
is probably better than it ever was
did you happen to see any of the
theories of everything podcast prior to
this
no and i still haven't and it's not
being rude to you it is your confidence
the same thing you experienced that uh i
literally do work 18-hour days all of
the time
well thank you for not under duress it's
just so much okay if you can see or hear
this type in
blue eyes chaos max dragon into the live
chat blue eyes chaos max dragon
we're live linda welcome
thank you kurt i'm glad to be here
just making sure it's all copacetic on
my end okay
so linda i watched a strange harvest and
i saw there was this lady who via
hypnotherapy was able to see a cow being
abducted and i'm wondering if there are
any other cases of people seeing a
cattle being mutilated or being taken
but not in some post-induced altered
state
probably one of the most interesting
aspects at the beginning of the research
when i started calling sheriffs and
deputies
back in for the first time september of
1979
i was provoked by headlines that were in
colorado newspapers and television using
the word
animal mutilations returned
and i had been doing medical programming
for the abc station in boston
have moved to denver and was hired to be
director of special projects but i was
personally not aware of the animal
mutilation phenomena having been working
at knbc in los angeles and wcvb in
boston so that when i saw these
headlines
the first thing that i did was contact
sheriffs in some of the counties that
were listed
and one of them was sheriff tech's
graves up in logan county in colorado
and
drove up for a probably it was about a
three or four hour meeting
in which he brought out polaroids
and
documents
and he had been investigating animal
mutilation since uh i think it was 1970
or 71 and i'm now a decade later in his
office
asking him as director of special
projects
it was sheriff tex graves who told me
linda i'll save you some time
the perpetrators are creatures from
outer space
and then he began to tell me why which
included his own interviews with
ranchers that he had gone out to
investigate
bloodless trackless mutilations who said
at night
i saw a beam
i saw a beam coming out of something
circular in the night sky
it was coming down into the pasture
the rancher would say i was terrified
ran back to the ranch house and then
when the sun came up
went out and there was
one of his cattle
bloodlessly
mutilated meaning an ear
is taken
on the sky facing the animals are
usually on one side
and it's the sky facing that always is
where the ear is taken
the eye is taken sometimes a circle of
flesh around the eye
the jaw like a key hole
they called it the keyhole cut where
it's like this
and everything is removed
and fresh shining bone
and was one of the points that
sheriff tex graves said not only were
the ranchers reporting that they were
seeing beams of light coming into their
pasture where they would find a
mutilated animal but you can ask a
veterinarian how would you get
this
tissue
off of a jawbone
when of the only way to get a jawbone
clean and polished is to boil
and that is not happening between in the
hours between the day and when they're
found in the morning
and when this one particular rancher the
sheriff tex graves was saying
saw the beam of light
eventually i would hear in
discussions with other sheriffs and
deputies
where they would be talking with a
rancher who would say
they saw an animal rise in the beam of
light
but it was not a cell phone age we're
talking about the early 70s so you have
human testimony of what they have seen
but you do not have
video recordings or photographs
and
i think it was the sheriff tex graves
comment
linda i'll save you some time
the perpetrators are creatures from
outer space
and that was to me the most shocking
statement to me in the very first
interview with a sheriff that i
conducted
did the person see an eight a cattle a
cow going up or he just saw the beam at
that point
that particular rancher saw the beam
others would then
later on tell me about how they saw an
animal rise
or be lowered and in
my work uh glimpses of other realities
high strangeness
and in facts and eyewitnesses it's a
two-volume book
there is a story
out of
oregon
and that was an eyewitness that i was
able to interview
he was working as a ranch hand was
staying out in a trailer house where
they had
some cattle that might
be giving birth and so he would stay out
to help if anything happened with the
cattle
and he
was uh he started hearing a sound and
couldn't understand what he was hearing
on a clear night it sounded like
branches breaking and he left the
trailer house
and to his complete and total
astonishment
he was seeing
a light there was a beam but cattle were
dropping
from whatever this light was in the sky
they were dropping down through the
trees breaking branches and it was like
11 animals that he himself watched drop
from the sky
and that was
in southeastern oregon and it's one of
the
cases that i have documented by talking
with him and others who were in oregon
at the time
and the animal mutilations have had
cyclings in certain areas whether it's
the united states canada mexico central
america cycling with respect to time
what do you mean
it is a global phenomena that cycles
if uh
in this instance like i can think of
times
well there was a rancher named blazing
game
and he had a big ranch that was north of
colorado springs in colorado
and i interviewed him when i was working
on my documentary as strange
harvest and
then about three years later
he called me at the station and he said
i want you to know that hill pasture
that we talked about where i had the
mutilations he said this year i decided
i was not going to put any cattle on
that hill pasture and linda this is the
first year
in four years i have not had a
mutilation
and that has always been to me another
one of those data points that has been
puzzling
that you get the sense in the animal
mutilations as if there was a grid on
the planet
and that certain latitude longitudes
would continue to repeat over time
where a rancher would say i had the
mutilations on in this pasture and no
other pastures
on that hill pasture
and that is also a puzzle why do you
think that is
well if we are dealing with
extraterrestrial biological entities as
sheriff tex graves said
their approach to our planet
could be
let's say let's say because one of the
hypotheses is
that the reason for the animal
mutilations relates to the fact that the
gray beings that have been re probably
reported more than any other in
abductions and have been seen
two cowboys
in colorado
they were reported and called the
sheriff
that they saw
two small gray beings literally float in
the air up over a corral fence and down
into a corral scared them and they ran
away and then they come back and there
is a mutilated cow in the corral so they
had a direct link with the grey beans
that
one of the hypotheses
is that
all these different types that are
reported around the world
grey types reptilian types tall blondes
tall whites all of these different types
of beings
that there may be
an evolutionary
relationship between
say grays that may have been working on
our planet for centuries maybe thousands
and thousands of years
we
are a species that has only existed on
earth for 45 000 years in the crossfade
with neanderthalensis
so we would not have any firsthand
information about what was happening on
our earth in terms of
extraterrestrials and animal mutilations
a prior to let's say the 20th century
and one of the hypotheses is that the
harvest may be because there are certain
chemicals
that beings that have been on this
planet for
millennia
may have developed that they had a need
for something
to be healthy
and that can only get it from earth life
and that that is why there is this
periodic
cyclic global harvest of blood and
tissue from animals both
domestic
and wild the
forest service had photographs of deer
elk
other places kangaroos
reindeer are there ever small animals
like rats or cats
cats cut in half
all over the planet
usually leaving
the front half more than the back half
no blood inside no organs inside that's
part of the animal mutilations
a marmot
a marmot was reported in aspen colorado
to me
uh it was a forest service guy and he
found the marmot laid out on a rock
and it had the same ear
eye
jaw so here's this little animal that
had the same excisions as the larger
they're all mammals
um no because
i think
well what category would you put a
kangaroo in mammal
okay
okay so
they're not reptiles
there have been uh snakes
in england
that had been found where a fox was
mutilated or a
rabbit was mutilated and then they would
find
nearby a reptile snake that was cut with
organs
removed very specifically from inside
the snake
with no blood and no fluid and
completely dry
you mentioned that there was a report of
two greys and then they came and floated
and i imagine that they're floating
without a beam so the beam was to bring
up a cow to make a cow float so they can
float on their own without
light let's say is there a difference
between a ground mutilation and one that
takes place in the craft itself
i don't know beyond the fact that in
myerfiles.com
i have about 3 000 in-depth reports in
science and environment and real x-files
and there is a fascinating report
where there were two men they had gone
out to hunt
and
they uh were in sleeping bags
and they both become aware
that
that there is some kind of a beam
that is taking one of the hunters up out
of a sleeping bag the other watches and
then they both
find themselves inside of a craft
and that was a case where
a cow
was all hooked up to tubes to a strange
technology
and their testimony was that
telepathically that they were receiving
information from a clearly looking
standing up
alligator lizard
type
this is what we do
we
we take your this animal and it's
important that it remain alive while we
are removing the fluids
it's the only case that i know of where
there was a
effort to try to communicate to humans
who were watching
a process of lifting this was a cow
going up in a beam of light
that the hunters saw
and then showing what had happened now
why that would be
that is part of the mystery why is it
that the for the most part animal
mutilations have taken place around the
planet usually in what would be the dark
hours of night that would be the general
and then the animals found in the
morning
but in these cases which are not many
where there have been humans who see the
beam
in this case
the only case i know where two men are
then up inside of the craft and being
shown this is what we do
why did that happen and why hasn't it
happened on lots of other cases
it is part of the mystery
of non-human intelligences who have been
interacting with this planet from
government uh testimony to me from
people who have worked in nsacia
saying
as one man told me in december of 1999
he was retiring from the defense
intelligence agency
and we had a seven-hour meeting that
took a month to put together
and he said
that
the
the whole issue of how long
all of this had been going on he said
our government
has proof
that three extraterrestrial
civilizations
have been competing with each other and
in conflict on our planet for at least
270 million years
and when i said what is the proof
he said linda if i told you
it would be a danger to you and to me
both
but 270 million years
is going back before the time of the
dinosaurs
did they give any indication that the
cows were being lowered slower when you
said that they heard rustling when the
cows were being lowered into some ground
are they being are they being dropped
are they being lowered slowly
i've heard both
uh the one in uh oregon
that was the first hand uh the cowboy
watching because he heard the breaking
limbs and sees the animals dropping he
could see a beam but they were being
dropped
from the beam through the trees
other cases
people see they like the linda porter
case that you mentioned
she and her daughter see a calf rising
up in a beam of light and then they find
themselves in the craft with gray beings
that are taking
thin slices from testicles and other
organs
that they associate with the calf that
they saw go up in the beam of light
so you have variations on
watching something
be lowered
i've had cases they've seen it lowered
all the way but the rancher becomes
terrified and runs back to a ranch house
and does not come back to that pasture
till the sun is up and then they find a
mutilated animal other people see them
dropped
and
and why
for the most part the vast majority
don't see either
they find the animals
what's meant precisely when you say that
there is no blood i've heard this many
times so does that mean that if i was to
take my finger and touch the inside that
it would come out without any red or is
it just that there isn't a drastic
amount of blood it's radically reduced
uh you have uh
one or two of my books and you look at
the photographs and you see
an excision
eye
ear
the jaw the genitals the rectum over and
over thousands and thousands of photos
around the world the same
there's not even fluid there's no blood
there's no blood oozing there's no blood
on the ground
everything
is what about urine or excrement
i don't
recall i don't think a single
animal mutilation case
uh
because usually in 90 of the cases the
rectal tissue is removed
and that means it's a hole
and there's no blood and there's no
fluid
and as a lot of sheriffs have said to me
it felt like sandpaper to touch the
tissue
it was so dry
you mentioned that trump knows more
about ufos than he lets on why do you
think that
oh i guess it's because i have had
conversations with people who have
worked in intel agencies during the
trump administration
and they have said that the current
administration
knows more than they're saying and it
was in the context of my asking
do you think that
uh president trump
will be the
administration to announce that we're
not alone in this universe
and so that would be the discussion and
then
people would say well he knows more than
he says
so i'm just going through my notes here
you mentioned ones that are at least at
least once that arts parts will levitate
in the presence of a certain magnetic
field and i'm assuming that's at room
temperature now what makes you say this
where did you get that from
the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
material
it
came in
two sections
uh it was 1996 april
and
i was doing uh
probably two
two to three programs with art bell
almost every month at that time
and
the first
shipment that came with a metal that i
got to alcoa aluminum
to find out what it was because we
figured it was aluminum and alcoa came
back and said where did you get this
it's
99.74
pure aluminum and we don't manufacture
aluminum at this purity
and then
within two or three weeks after getting
the aluminum and my starting the
research and reporting
pretty much pretty regularly with art on
coast to coast and another show we did
called dreamland
came another shipment
and by then i had established with a
professor that i knew
through crop circle investigations at
the university of michigan
we got a second box and it was clearly
more complex
layered pieces silver on one side black
on the other
and i called the professor at the
university of michigan and said we've
got a second box
can you take a look at a piece i'm going
to send you and see if we can
get elements
do some electron microscopy all of which
he could do at the university
that led to in my books you see the
analysis
that it was
97.6
a layer
in one of the layers in the silver and
black
and the 97.6 percent was magnesium
2.4 percent zinc
so it was like an alloy in one layer
that was silver
the next layer
was only one to four microns it was
extremely thin and it was bismuth
so we had
alternating layers
of bismuth magnesium
with
uh
with a magnesium zinc with bismuth
approximately 26 layers making these
silver and black pieces that were maybe
a little less than a quarter of an inch
thick and there were several in this box
as soon as i began reporting what the
professor was finding in terms of the
elements i started getting
phone calls and emails from people
saying
we know from
our research that what you have
is
uh going to be from the bottom of a
craft
well it turned out that we had a letter
that came
from a diary of
a
grandfather
who had worked in security at roswell
according to the sender who was a army
sergeant at the time i got to talk with
him on the phone
and he said my grandfather
said this was in one of the crashes in
47
and that he and men were assigned to
ring a wedge-shaped craft
that glowed with light underneath for
about four hours
and essentially that the grandfather
left his
relative
this diary saying that he had done
something that would get anybody else in
real trouble he had gone over
and with his own hand had pulled some of
the bottom that was glowing of this
craft
and these are the pieces that were in a
box
and
so we had
the diary
that said that the
black and silver pieces came from the
bottom of a wedge-shaped craft
and
eventually within a very short period of
time of my reporting these various
pieces and questions on the air what
could this be
hal put off
who is a physicist who has worked on
many many ufo-related subjects
he got in touch with me and said linda i
would like to be able to study this
bismuth magnesium zinc material
and
hal put off and
people who were working in
semiconductors i started getting
requests
from a variety of different scientists
and then we started cutting pieces of
these originals so that i could send
them out with uh releases that everybody
would return what they were studying to
me which is how i kept them for the
pieces for
20 years
what i began to
realize that from the people who were
getting the material
and that i was working with
they started talking about we think that
this is
material
that interacts with a field
that would neutralize gravity
that's
that's how all of it very complex series
of tests and reports
evolving into people saying
this material in a field but what is the
field
we never were able to demonstrate this
never but that was the context from
people who had other information that
the bismuth magnesium zinc so now jump
to today in 2022
there are all kinds of reports that have
been emerging in the last year or two
about bismuth
and magnesium
being one of the keys to certain kinds
of skins
that have been
verified in ufos
that would have some
relationship to neutralizing gravity
in very specific fields
so that's what's happened from 1996
up to 2022 an evolution
of a whole variety of researchers and
now today
there are people who are willing to say
that
i was looking into the research on this
and i couldn't find any published
research only reports of other people
like hal put off saying well it
it's right it displays anti-gravity
properties however a published piece of
research was by mick west
and he showed that some of the images of
the aluminum art parts
they looked like a fin sheet which was
found in car radiators and around the
year 19
25 i don't know what you're re i do not
know what you're referring to i know
that uh my work with the professor at
the university in michigan was the very
first work
there there was no no other and that was
done we had electron microscope
images
we had
microscope images
we were doing periodic table
element
analyses that
led to my
talking with art and saying look i would
like to find out
from somebody who uh where we could do
um an um
ion microprobe
which is a very sophisticated instrument
and find out if there is anything in the
magnesium that might be outside of what
is considered normal magnesium on the
earth
and that is one of the elements that had
come up in other ufo stories in previous
years
where a famous case down in south
america there was a magnesium dropped
from a ufo onto a beach and it turned
out that one of the reports was that it
was not earth-based ratios
well that led to art and i uh split the
cost of it i remember it was an 850 bill
and we split it
for me to go to carnegie institute in
washington dc that had at that time in
july of 1996
the only ion microprobe that would be
able to do
a study of the magnesium
and the bismuth
and
the
the
bismuth the magnesium and the zinc
and
it was about a seven or eight hour that
i was there at carnegie institute
and at one point i remember the ion
microprobe uh technical guy said
you know
i don't think
in all of my work here i do not think
i've ever looked at a thin bismuth layer
like this one to four microns
where i did not find also led adams
present because on a periodic table
bismuth and lead are right next to each
other and they would normally find some
led with bismuth and with regard to that
in particular i'm sorry to interrupt i
just want to
hurry this along so mick west and hit
and um you're saying that you haven't
seen the analysis by mick west
and from my reading of it it seems like
what's been displayed in arts parts at
least part of it
is like i mentioned what can be found in
fin sheet and car radiators in the 1920s
and there's a
no the refinement of
if i could just finish
finish on the ion microprobe uh it's the
uh it's the most sophisticated uh
technical
apparatus and we were looking at the
purity or the percentage in the bismuth
layer the zinc layer and the magnesium
layer that's not easy to do and the ion
microprobe that day when i said it we
used it for seven or eight hours
and that uh when eric howery was the
iron microprobe technician and he was
talking about how the bismuth was pure
that he was not finding lead
and it turned out that the magnesium
had 11
more magnesium 24 than our baseline
magnesium we were using as a comparison
that wasn't enough to kick it into this
is automatically extraterrestrial
magnesium but it was definitely unusual
enough for him he wrote up a report
which i have published in my books
talked about
so the
the elemental compositions of those
layers and knowing that the bismuth was
one to four microns this is very thin
making up these layers
this was
a
hard data
in the period of time that we were
receiving this material in 1996
and that is what i was reporting and
finding the electron microscope and
eventually at carnegie institute that is
why hal put off and other scientists
became very interested and that began
the next level
of doing agreements where i would send
out some of this magnesium bismuth zinc
to them
to do tests
and
they sending back and saying this is
definitely unusual this is not some
deposition as some people tried to say
oh it's just a layered deposition from a
lab no no
that's not true i had a notebook i think
i ended up at the end of 1996 with 119
people and labs that i had gone to
getting information about the bismuth
magnesium zinc and it included a man and
a exotic metals manufacturer in new york
city
and when i told him what we had found at
the university of michigan
and in carnegie institute in terms of
what these layers were i remember the
man laughed and said
look
i can tell you
you you can't put
bismuth and magnesium together
they will delaminate
and so
we had uh we had the hard
evidence of what they were made of and
what the layers were and how pure they
were
but metal exotic metal manufacturer
couldn't even recognize how you would
put bismuth and magnesium together in
layers
have you heard of the betterton cruel
process
or has anyone mentioned that to you
say that again betterton kroll so it was
invented around the 1920s
and it was a way and it still is a way
of refining lead to produce similar
amounts of
ratios that have been reported and see
when i watch a show like forensic files
sometimes i see
anyone can do that you can just watch
the show forensic files sometimes you'll
see these experts and they'll say this i
don't know where this came from this is
not even from
this is and i'm an expert in the field
that i've never seen either this
isotopic ratio or this amount of
percentage of elements in it and then
there's some pedestrian explanation
afterward so even experts can
can miss so that's why i'm wondering if
you've heard of betterton crowell
it is a lead analysis process
no it's a refinement it's a refinement
process that was invented around the
1920s or so
no i mean
you're so far afield
from the fundamental original research
that was done at the university of
michigan
and then carnegie institute
of pure bismuth
in one to four micron layers
and then
zinc
2.4 percent
magnesium 96
percent
given
it has to add up to 100
and that was repeated at carnegie
institute
so the only elements present
in these layers
were the bismuth
thin one to four micron layer
with the magnesium zinc
alternating
very regularly
black bismuth silver magnesium zinc
a whole series like a torque cake
but only a quarter of an inch high
because the layers the bismuth was so
thin
i understand and those those
what i'm saying is that was the 1996
original hard evidence that would hold
up in a court of law
uh this is all that is in these layered
metals
so what's happening with those meta
materials right now are they simply
sitting around is the krata agreement
going to produce a public analysis of it
i had uh the medals
working with hal put off and with others
up to
uh august of 2018. so i started
those years in
april of 1996
and by 2018
hal put off had joined with tom delonge
and
lou elizondo and others in that to the
stars group where they
had a goal that they would take
they would have money raise money
to have
exotic technologies
examined and then reported to the white
world as opposed to being constantly
covered up in the black world that was
the concept
and hal uh put off asked me
in uh he'd had the bismuth magnesium
zinc
three different times had written up
his analysis for me that i had reported
and is in my books
and
jacques vallee
in 2017
he had a piece of bismuth magnesium zinc
from me for most of that year
and by then it was because if you go
from 1996 to 2017 to 2018
there had been more and more information
about the role that bismuth might play
in terms of neutralizing gravity
and so people who had had the bismuth
magnesium zinc 20 years earlier we're
now coming back and saying we want to
study it more for x y and z
and by that time how put off had written
to me and said
i would like to see a study
of the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
material
subjected to terahertz frequency
he said i think that if we could
generate terahertz frequency at this
specific level that this could turn into
a lifting body
and terahertz frequency had not even
been in the discussion in the 90s
it came
in those 2017-2018
years
and it was also associated terahertz
frequency had come up in one of the
reports about what might have happened
at bentwaters in england when john
burroughs and others had had encounters
with lights and there was a report that
was finally released in the
2012-2013 period
talking specifically
about ufos emitting terahertz frequency
that probably had to do with
neutralizing gravity but what they had
learned
was that terahertz frequency
could damage human hearts
or organs that had spaces in them like a
heart does
at certain levels in frequencies of
terahertz that had never been reported
prior to
2012 and 13.
so coming up
even further to 2017
and 2018.
hal had the bismuth magnesium zinc
wanted to try to see if he could get
terahertz frequency and they had done
tests and they had not been able to
generate the terahertz frequency that he
wanted
jacques valet had a company on the west
coast they said they thought they could
generate the terahertz frequency all of
the year of 2017 jacques had trying and
they couldn't
then by then
to the stars the group that included hal
put off
they came to me and said
we have a variety of interests including
other scientists who
have information and we would like to be
able to work with you as you have with
hal and with jacques and others
and we will have a piece of bismuth
magnesium zinc and we will return it to
you
because we're now going to try to see if
we can
match hal's uh projection that if we got
terahertz frequencies at of this very
high level
it could turn into a lifting body
and long story sh you know long story
short
it's been going through all these
different rounds of research and being
returned to me
and i got a call in the spring of 2018
after to the stars had gotten a piece
that was to come back to me and they
said
we still have not been able to find
a civilian commercial lab that can
project the terahertz frequency at the
level we need
but the united states army is interested
linda we can make you a third party
to the stars
and me and the army
but we need to be able with your
agreement
because all these agreements were with
me to keep returning the pieces to me
over all these years
that if you want to be a third party
we want to send the bismuth magnesium
zinc layered piece to the army
because they think that they can
generate the terahertz frequency
and i asked them could i think about it
for 24 hours
and i thought
if
anybody
ends up in
an agreement with any of the military
branches of the united states
i could not really foresee
the peace coming back to me
and that's why i proposed that they sell
it to me
for all of the costs that i had incurred
from 1996 to 2018 which was considerable
i traveled i flew i took that
so
so uh sales
officially
on one piece i still have another piece
went from me to
to the stars
and they delivered the piece to the
united states army which i am assuming
it is still there but they're up to now
if you and i are speaking in january of
2022
i have not heard of any breakthrough
on testing the material
with terahertz and it turning into
an a body that would float
if it has
they're keeping it close to their chest
i personally have no doubt
that a physicist in 2014
at a conference
who came to me and said
with a lot of noise around which was
protective
he said i just want you to know
in the 1970s
at area 51
s4 underground
he said i worked
on the layered bismuth
and
magnesium zinc material
this is in
at s4 for everything i just said that
bob lazar
supposedly worked
and and this physicist
showed me proof
that i cannot discuss
about what he had done and where he had
been
and he said
i had a piece
of the bismuth magnesium zinc
that was three feet by six feet linda
it came off it was a skin of a
wedge-shaped ufo the diary that came to
art belle and me in 1996
was typed that this was
pulled off
of the bottom skin of a wedge-shaped
vehicle now the physicist is telling me
that he had worked with a three foot by
six foot
piece
and that
its function
was to be in parallel with a pure
aluminum remember that was the first
shipment the first shipment we got in
april of 1996 was an aluminum that alcoa
called me on and said where did you get
this it was 97.6 or something percent
pure aluminum and
alcoa said we don't manufacture in this
kind of purity
and the physicist is the one who opened
up for me why
and why these two would have come in the
different boxes from the grandfather
the physicist said what we learned at
area 51 s4
is that it was the pure aluminum that
had iridium
placed atomically in it something we
cannot do
and it had
the pure aluminum was the outside skin
linda the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
was an inside skin the two skins of the
wedge-shaped objects
then
in some sort of creation or projection
of the terahertz frequency by the craft
with those two skins would turn it into
a lifting body
that was from a physicist
who proved to me who he was
who approached me in 2014. so this is a
complicated timeline
from 1996 getting the physical pieces
the physicist in 2014 telling me what he
was able to study and confirm
at area
51 s4
and then getting to the year 2017 and
2018 where chocolate and hal put off and
to the stars
wanted to study
also for the same reason terahertz
frequency mixed with that material could
turn it into a lifting body but as we
speak in january of 2022
no one yet
has publicly published anything
confirming that they have done that
i know that you don't know much about my
background linda i
i'm fairly naive in this subject my my
knowledge is so rudimentary and there's
so many names in so many places it's
difficult for me to contextualize and
make sense so if my questions
are
come across as as rude please forgive me
it's just my
my innocuous naivety okay so
i sent you my book so you could see the
photographs and on the bismuth magnitude
and i will include a link to all of the
books and what you've sent me in the
description for people who would like to
check them out so here's what i'm
wondering when you sold the materials to
tom de long it sounds like you were
aware he was working with the government
however the government i was told okay
however we believe the government to be
covering up evidence on this topic so
i'm curious how did you feel about that
and also if i go like this again i'm not
trying to be rude i'm just saying like
okay we have to wrap this up because
there's so we have a significant amount
of ground to cover
but i'll just go like this instead
but i felt like it was unclear on your
side and i wanted to make sure that it
was clear because this is really
important this material is very very
important okay so how did you feel about
that you gave it to someone who was
working with the government when we're
ambivalent about the
government given that they was uh yeah
it would it was a a kind of sad irony
that from 1996
to 20 uh 1918 2018
that i had shepherded
these materials all of those years
and had gone to various labs and had
worked with even stephen chu the
inventor of the
super semiconductor
and people were looking at it for all
kinds of various reasons not just ufos
uh and a lifting body there were lots of
scientists very interested in the
layered combination
and
when
jacques
had been so enthusiastic
and in 2017 thought that they were going
to be able to generate the terahertz
that hal calculated and they weren't and
hal came back
and said we now think we have a lab it
was very clear
that the test of the terahertz
frequencies at frequencies very near
flipping into the frequency of light
terahertz look at an electromagnetic
spectrum
terahertz
goes right into
uv light
and so that it was an issue of how do
you control a certain high frequency of
terahertz
and directed into the bismuth magnesium
zinc
without it flipping into
the light frequency that's as i
understand was one of the problems
and so if jacques valet and hal put off
had not been able to get the terahertz
frequency test
done
and to the stars comes and says the
united states army thinks that they can
do it now there is a conflict that i had
shepherded to this material for a very
long time but there was also the realism
i don't have the ability to generate
terahertz frequencies
i don't have labs in which they i can go
into an electron microscopic level
i always was trying to get that to
people who would report results
so
it seemed to me that it was just a final
practical
answer
that i would sell
a piece
keeping another piece i see i see and if
the united states army could solve this
it's my country
this is
for our
uh united states of america if in fact
they can crack uh what this skin and the
two skins and terahertz frequencies
might produce
that it was had come to sort of the end
of the road of what to do next because
hal put off and jacques malay
were two scientists that
seemed like they might have a reasonable
chance of getting the the test done
and then it would have been reported
publicly
but
it if i had kept the peace
because i didn't want it going to a
military operation
what would i do with it if
the major researchers
like hal and jacques
had come to a dead end at that point so
that was part of my thinking
so we'll move on from this topic because
i feel like i'm harping on it too much
just so you know i have an extremely
analytical mind so i like details
okay let's talk quickly about crop
circles and then we're going to get to
some audience questions what do you
believe to be the best
hypothesis for why crop circles exist
what are they trying to convey what is
their purpose
on my very first year and first first
trip to england it was 1992
and i was out in one of the
big patterns that left everybody
awestruck
because the size and the perfection
no footprints
they were astonishing in 1992 at the
sort of the beginning of people paying
attention
and
a man
walked over to where i was and he
was making comments about
it's remarkable isn't it there's even
three or four layers there's braiding
and so we're now talking about the
astonishing details in a formation
and then he said
well you know i
i know somebody who works for the
central intelligence agency he was
probably talking about himself i've had
that experience there will be people who
are working in intel and they'll say
somebody i know who works in intel but
it's usually their first hand
information
he said he told me that they're very
interested in these crop formations and
that they've got a satellite now that is
trying to get satellite images of every
crop formation that is happening on the
world
because they are convinced that what we
are dealing with
is mathematical language
from another intelligence that is using
the crop formations to judge the
accuracy of their travel in time
can you explain that
well he was basically saying that
our government in the cia
had come to the conclusion that the
astonishing crop formations
would be somebody not earth somebody
else's test
of a time travel technology that was
leaving this mathematical language on
the surface of the earth
and i bring that up because that was one
of the first discussions that i ever had
with anybody on my very first trip to
england
and it set a tone
that
you when you were in those crop
formations in 92 this is before all of
the uh team satan hoaxers that came into
the fields in 95 and 96 and were
apparently deliberately trying to
destroy or whatever they were doing 92
was a year where crop formations were it
was very pure
there were no hoaxers there were no
nothing about what would come
three or four years later
and
that man talking to me
about the idea that we could be looking
at a mathematical language
that was being used to test time travel
for me it was like a sudden
wow
i never ever would have thought that way
about crop formations and so he gave me
a gift
it was it was first trip one of the
first formations i was in i have that
discussion
and it uh so uh it so stretched my mind
to looking at crop formations
differently for which i'm very grateful
because eventually
i was in england uh studying crop
formations doing soil collections seed
collections for
the biophysicists in michigan michigan
wc loving good
i was very very involved every summer
from 92 until
um
probably up through 1999. i went every
summer and i was involved in the studies
and the scientific analysis and how we
found there was coatings of iron on
seed heads that no one knew how
all of it
and
eventually
i would say that
i've
i personally
had in my hands
walked with my feet
through
woven
where it would be just like a perfect if
you were weaving
but 300 feet in diameter
or 500 feet in diameter the patterns
could be huge
with perfect weaving
but it would be not just the surface
weaving
you would get down and lift up the
surface that would be woven just like a
braid
and then there would be a whole other
layer
that was coming at 90 degree angles and
you would lift that up some of these
were 12 inches
down before you could get to soil yeah
every layer
maybe two or three inches times four or
five
it would be a different angle different
pattern
and it would be four or five deep
how in the world would anybody do that
and not leave tracks
and
i think that it
it really shifted into a whole other
gear for me
that year in 92 when
uh i went with a group to milk uh it was
milk hill
a place where there were crop formations
every year it turned out later
and
it was our very first
pattern we had met
people from the united states and
england
and you parked up here on top of the
hill and you came in to the top of the
hill where the white horse was and then
you're looking down on this it was a 400
i think it was 430 feet long bigger than
a football field
and this was spirals of circles and
paths was huge
this is the very first crop formation
and
i started down one of the tram lines
because we were all trying to make sure
the farmers knew that we were not going
to tread on any crop
and i started down
one of the
tram lines
and the group behind me
they started going down different tram
lines
so each one of us was coming down to
this huge formation in different tram
lines and when i got down to where i
wanted to try to walk in based on what
i'd seen from above
i had my 35 millimeter nikon hanging
around my neck and i had learned uh in
other work that i had done in the united
states i would always come in anything i
was doing animal mutilations or whatever
i would bring the camera up and i would
start taking photos as i approached
and i found those photographs to be so
valuable to me in research and that's
what i did
so i'm walking to the edge now of this
big crop formation
and i'm lifting up and taking photos
my
intent was to go through the edge now
onto this formation and take close-ups
and as i started to try to move through
the edge
it was like a warm jello it's what it
felt like that i walked into something
that had substance
right along the edge of this crop
formation
and i stopped and backed up and reached
out and i could touch it again it felt
like warm jello
and i was so puzzled
and
everybody else was at the far end this
way because i was going to that way so i
wasn't talking with anybody
and i came up with my camera
and i
went like higher than i would have and i
started taking photos
and as i did i moved forward and i felt
a release like something let go
of whatever this warm jello was
and when i walked into now the circle
i suddenly felt like that i was uh
almost
violating
and i
i bent down and this was the one crop
formation right at the beginning
that i felt
it's seven layers
there were seven layers crossed with
different 90 degree angles all the way
down and i went down to where i could
get dirt i could feel dirt with my
fingers
and it was up to here on my elbow
so it was that deep people think they're
flat no
many many many complex layers
see now linda i think similarly to you
in that
that person who came up with the
idea that this is some rather than a
rather than an intent to communicate
it's an artifact
of a calibration technique
that the crop circles are so what led
him to think that
the man who approached me and said that
he knew somebody in the cia
who knows i mean
in all of my professional career uh it
seems to me that
when you begin
intensely studying something
investigating
however you explain it there will be
people who end up giving you information
that becomes a key i have experienced
that over and over and over
almost sometimes as if
there is a
sense of
being directed to look at things that
you would not normally and why does that
happen
i don't know
but in crop formations in that day
i think
back of how many people
would end up
walking into a crop formation and saying
x y or z
and then you are learning something new
and you just keep going deeper and
deeper and deeper and all that work that
i did
with wc loving good
doing and collecting soil and seeds and
plants and all of the things that we did
for at least a decade
he was a
a very very uh detailed intense
scientist
he became convinced
that there were energy systems
that were coming through the ionosphere
and that they were spinning and he gave
all of the
hard physics reasons for why he came to
those conclusions
and he was doing his own independent
paper
and then we learned that another
physicist in holland
is also had been collecting soil plants
and
samples like uh his himself like i was
doing for dr levingood
and both of these biophysicists end up
producing papers with the same
conclusion
that there were spinning
vortices
of charged particles that were coming
down and that the charged particles were
then affecting the plants
in whether they were going to stand or
go down
and that the complexity of the patterns
was signaled
by what they thought was happening in
the swirling patterns coming from the
ionosphere
so two completely different scientists
did these papers i got to meet and work
with both of them
and my point is
there was no precedent
the the this was all dependent upon
people who had physics backgrounds
biology backgrounds who became so
interested
in the phenomena of weaving
90 degree angles
all of the geometry and math that seemed
to be inherent in these crop formations
that attracted men who were professional
in biophysics and then ended up
producing papers
that led to a question
what would cause
a spinning complex of energy coming down
through the ionosphere that would go all
the way down
to crops
in fields all over the planet this was
not happening just in england
and no one had even
uh confronted such
information before
linda here's a personal question before
we get to audience questions but
something i think about as this channel
gets larger
how cautious are you
that you're being used as a
disinformation
agent unwittingly
i started in 1979
as director of special projects
at the cbs station in denver
i had been doing all the medical
programming for the abc station in
boston
before i was hired at the cbs station in
denver
before i did all the medical programming
in boston i was doing all kinds of
science and environment reporting for
knbc in los angeles
at stanford university my master's film
was
their very first efforts to use
computers to analyze particle
bombardments in the stanford linear
accelerator
everything in my work
from 1968
up to
uh being hired
at the cbs station
and then
in 1979 there
the headlines about animal mutilations
everything in my professional life with
science
medicine and the environment
proving hypotheses with evidence
working in labs
collecting enough data that you can
hypothesize
x y and z of whatever the issue is
so my training and my life
was always in the context of science and
medicine as it is to this day
the animal mutilations which are
physical evidence all over the planet
that i start going to animal mutilations
with formal in solution and a scalpel or
scissors
so that i can cut the mutilators an
excision to send to a lab
which i did many many times
was also part of the whole building of a
context this is not something that could
be done by
by a human
because hearts
would be found in necropsies missing
inside of a 1700 pound cow
or 2 000 pound bull
the heart would be missing
the pericardium that surrounded the
heart would be collapsed in the chest
no clotted blood
no fluid
no surgery on the outside of the body
i took that evidence to a doctor at rose
medical center in denver i said how
would you take a 9 by 11 by 12 inch
heart
out of a grown cow or a bull
without any surgery
and the
doctor that is in my uh documentary is
strange harvest talking about this said
you can't
but he said what this reminds me of is
linda i have
in my own medical experience i have this
idea that maybe in
50 years from now we will have molecular
extraction surgery
and it will mean it will be frequency
and a frequency will go through the skin
the cartilage the bone and maybe it is
going to operate on a gallbladder
and nothing else will be affected
because it will be molecular specific
surgery
it's now 2022
we do not have molecular specific
surgery on the earth even now
and yet in 1979
43 years ago
when i began my very first research of
the animal mutilations
finding
through necropsy
and talking with doctors and labs
that what was being found in the
necropsies of the animals was impossible
the removal of organs from inside bodies
with no surgery surgery on the surface
so
from my point of view
there is
any
any suggestion
that i would be
in ever at any point in my life
following somebody around or something
around is preposterous to me
let me repeat the question
i
i mentioned that i
wonder about
it's so difficult to study this field
linda as you know you've been in this
for decades
it's so difficult because there's so
much disinformation it's fraught with
disinformation contradictory information
as well
so
what this information has the
implies that someone had the intent of
spreading it whereas contradictory may
just be
varied reports so when it comes to
disinformation in particular
how what do you do to prevent yourself
being used as a disinformation
agent and or what burden of proof must
someone satisfy in order for you to
promulgate what they're saying
or have them on your show etc
i just outline to you
my entire background has always been in
medicine and science and the environment
therefore i approach every single
project
that i have ever done
what can be proved
what laboratory work can be done
what
experts do i go to that is the modus
operandi of my work
if the cia nsa dia and the other 15
intel agencies over the last 45 50 years
or 80 years going back to world war ii
were told that
they had to keep the public
from knowing anything about
extraterrestrial biological entities
mutilating animals around this planet at
all costs
and in 1979 i'm an emmy award-winning
peabody honored producer
and i
take seriously an investigation of
animal mutilations
i've been told
linda
you broadsided the united states
government
why
and the answer that came to me this is
literal because i've never forgotten it
they never thought that a credible
journalist would touch animal
mutilations with a hundred foot pole
still
i have never ever once been afraid to
look at evidence
to get professionals to develop evidence
that is the hallmark of all of my work
from stanford university i was at
stanford university working on a
master's degree in communication from
1966 to 68.
my work there i did a documentary for
the stanford medical center that they
used for 19 years after i graduated and
they sent me a beautiful letter thanking
me
as a master's degree student doing a
documentary with the stanford medical
center that they used for 19 years
my master's thesis
was
was stanford linear accelerator
for the very first time trying to see if
they could use computers that could do
the labor intensive analysis of atomic
bombardments
so i'm saying
that from my being a
person in their early 20s
getting a master's degree at stanford
university
every single thing that i did from there
on was still in the context of
everything that i had learned and
applied in all of the medical
programming science programming and
environment programming that i have done
and have earned emmy and a peabody for
so i'm not a person who goes
goes off well here's at one other point
the intelligence agencies
when they are ordered
the way we can hurt her
or him
is to try to discredit their work
that is a
old and tried intel
control mechanism
that doesn't mean
that when they float
whatever they're going to float
which i've seen preposterous things come
from the government about animal
mutilations
all i can do
is be the science medic
medic
all i can be is the science medical and
environment
reporter and producer writer director
editor that i have always been
and i am to this day
and
disinformation that the government of
the united states and other governments
work in 24 7.
wherever they're trying to apply that
rule let's make people look over here
because we don't want them to look here
well my entire career has been i want to
understand what's here not what they're
trying to make us look at over here and
i'll give you right now what the
government did this the shining ball
everybody look at this
it was a mantra
it was a mantra as if it had been
delivered to veterinarians and people on
purpose
just tell reporters that the animal
mutilations
are
done
by predators
disease
or satanic cults
nonsense absolute nonsense as soon as
you started doing any kind of legitimate
physical evidence which included
necropsies and finding
organs disappearing from inside of
animals with no surgery on the outside
but this shows
how easy it is for governments to just
to deflect
people's attention over here
and they do it on purpose
and it takes a lot of work and it takes
a lot of fortitude
to understand what the government is
using as deflection and what is really
going on and the way to do that is to
take every single subject
and you approach it from a scientific
medical
investigative what is the hard data
okay we'll get to some audience
questions this one comes from dan from
that ufo podcast he says cattle
mutilations are phenomenon that have
mystified people for a long time
you've been
involved in the research so what what
interesting results or correlations have
you found so i'll make an augmentation
to that linda i'll say what new
correlations have you uncovered or
surmised in the past two years
because your work is so vast i'm sure
it's changed
i would say the remarkable aspect of
animal mutilations is that they have
been reported on this planet
going back as far as one case 1904 in
australia
but the most
numbers of cases starting in the 1950s
and the 1960s
is how unchanged the phenomena has been
we're talking decades of animal
mutilations in both hemispheres around
this planet
and the
description is the same
going on if you are going back
with 75 years
ear missing eye tongue
jaw genitals rectum
and no blood
wounds that are dry to touch
and that that is the description around
the world in both hemispheres
okay andy from that ufo podcast as well
and the links to all of this are in the
description ufology has changed so much
in the past three or four years let
alone three or four decades how have
your views or opinions in that time
changed how do you see your place in the
subject now
oh
ufology
uh as a a word means nothing to me
means literally nothing to me
if we're talking about
what are
hard physical data
on planet earth
that has been linked
to aerial phenomena
that glows put downs beams where there
have been eyewitnesses who have seen
animals rise in a beam lowered in a beam
humans who have said that they have been
on the ground and have seen a beam come
down and then they're taken up in a beam
that's called eyewitness testimony
from other humans about something that
they have seen
and then the physical evidence in this
case are the animals
thousands and thousands and thousands of
domestic and wild animals
around this planet going back to at
least the 1950s and the early 1960s as a
beginning
have been affected the same way
there were so many reports of serrated
edges
in the united states for example and
canada in the 1970s that sheriffs and
deputies kept referring to them as
cookie cutter cuts
that is
evidentiary
you've got
eyewitnesses you have a phenomena that
does not change it keeps repeating
this is the animal mutilation phenomena
that sheriffs and deputies came to the
conclusion as sheriff tex graves told me
in colorado in 1979
the perpetrators linda are creatures
from outer space
it was a shocking statement
but i emphasize again
everything in my working world for the
decade before i started on mutilations
graduating from stanford in 1968
being hired uh at these different
stations and i did not start on a
strange harvest till 79 so a decade
later
it's the same approach
i go to veterinarians
i pay for necropsies
i went to labs
i looked at reports
that's
what i have done that has absolutely
nothing to do with quote unquote the
word ufology
okay you've just heard the themes of
ufos consciousness skinwalker
all topics that would make the
traditional skeptic scoff however it may
be the case that there's a paradigm
shift coming luckily short form has
compendious book summaries on the topics
of ufos consciousness spirituality
psychology philosophy and the meta issue
of anomalous data leading to radical
reorientations on scientific
understanding such as thomas coons the
structure of scientific revolutions
which is the short form book i was
reading most recently if you're like me
then there's a variety of books on your
kindle which are essentially left unread
there's a variety of tabs i'm looking at
them now which are left unread and then
i have to end up bookmarking them for
later short form makes learning what
i've already wanted to learn an
eminently trivial and quick task what's
great is that you can also get yourself
refreshed on books you've already read
since most of the time you would rather
read a summary than the entire book
again they even have exercises that will
prompt you for attention since there's
little points in accumulating knowledge
if you're simply going to forget it to
get a five day free trial visit short
form dot com slash t-o-e-toe and the
first 500 people will get an additional
20 off the annual subscription pause
this video if you have to and visit them
right now their ui is exceptionally
clean and me as someone with a
taxophobia genuinely appreciates that
actually short form just informed me
that the tow audience will receive an
additional 20 off the already discounted
annual subscription giving a total of 46
off when you visit short form.com t-o-e
now back to the podcast this question
comes from moon observer gillis or gills
and i'm gonna combine a couple because
they're similar so big fan of linda here
why do you think ets have not appeared
in person and i'm not talking about ufos
but revealing themselves to the entire
the entirety of humans let's say at new
york los angeles but it doesn't matter
we know ufos exist
but who are in them
is not clear okay why haven't ufos
revealed themselves
to the entirety of the human race
in december of uh 2021
i did an earth files report about heim
eshed he is the father of satellite
development in israel
and
in the process
of wanting to be able to get a full
english translation of the epilogue of
his memoir that came out then
i contacted a man who had volunteered to
do translations for me
hebrew to english
and i was able to get the entire heim
eched epilogue which is titled
we are not alone
that's the title that this uh longtime
satellite
um histori historic figure
put on his own epilogue and in there
were photographs of strange structures
on mars
he included ufo stories that had
happened in various places and were
investigated by anthropologists and
others
and one of the
questions that i said to the
hebrew english translator
is
does
haim eshed
have any insights from all of his work
having to do with the development of
satellites does he have any insights
about why
all of the other intelligence that he is
implying exists in his own memoir
why are we on a planet that is still
living in this strange straitjacket we
are the only intel intelligent life in
the universe
why he obviously knows that there is
something else other intelligences
and the answer that came back to me from
the
hebrew to english translator
is
haimashit says
that the release of the truth
is not for a human timeline
it is the timeline
of the others
why
why
would the non-humans
want
humanity to remain in the dark about
their existence their presence on our
planet in this solar system
what is it that the non-humans gain
by us being kept dumb and blind for
centuries
about the fact that we're not alone in
this universe
it is allegedly teeming with life but
certainly our government since world war
ii knows that extraterrestrial
biological entities a phrase that comes
from the truman administration
that is in documents extraterrest
biological entities
that isn't made up late in the 21st
century
those are those words are in documents
that have been released or leaked from
the 1940s
our government
may have run into information that they
found disturbing and that they wanted to
understand just like jaime
before they released
now we are at 2022
decades and decades of animal
mutilations human abductions
military pilots talking to investigative
reporters like me
learning about the fact that our nuclear
missile sites have had interactions by
ufos that have been able to bring a
missile down
or tend down
complete control
so i stand at 2022
with not a single question or doubt
that the
milky way galaxy is teeming with other
life and our government has known that
for a very long time
and we are still being insulated
and controlled
by them not officially announcing as
long as it is not officially announced
by governments it is still quote unquote
interpretive
from my point of view
we've had
the breakthroughs
because we have had physicists and
military people and scientists and intel
who have said they've been in a room
with an extraterrestrial biological
entity
they know that animal mutilations are
done by extraterrestrial biological
entities
there is all of this first-hand
testimony
and what
the intel agencies
have been able to do is still say until
they announce anything formally it's
still speculation
and that's from my point of view it's
nonsense because i know what i have done
what i have reported alone that is
forensic
it's evidentiary
and
now
we're in the straitjacket of
there are so many whistleblowers
that are coming from every direction in
multiple countries now
and they seem to be
overly irritated by the fact they know
that there are non-humans they know
about these very advanced craft
and they're frustrated
themselves
that we're not being told a truth which
they thought would have been opened up
by
now
so why is it being dragged out and will
the new web telescope finally be the
tool
that all of the scientists on the planet
including high meshed would agree
use the web
we know it could show our artificial
structures
on a planet at alpha centauri 4.2 light
years away
the telescope could be used as
oh
now we can announce
meanwhile
for centuries
extraterrestrial biological entities of
many kinds have interacted with and
harvested from
our planet the solar system and beyond
and our government knows it
do you think that some of the reason why
it's being concealed slash obfuscated by
both the government and the aliens
themselves supposedly do you think that
the
reason is for our own good like tom
delong thinks
or do you think there's a nefarious
reason to selfish reason one that one of
cupidity or gullosity
greed
since
since 2014
and a discussion that i had with a
physicist
who has firsthand information about
certain types of non-humans
and their interactions with this planet
our solar system and beyond
he gave me an insight that i think is
absolutely accurate because it has been
referenced in other documents that i
have seen since 2014.
linda there really is a threat
it is in the form of a very particular
kind of life form that we know is only
about 10 light years from the earth
and it is a threat
but i can also assure you that we are
working in collaboration
with tall whites and tall nordics and
they are allies
and they have the ability to fend off
the threat
but the government's point of view is
that as long as there is a potential
threat
it is
easier
to do the secret work
of doing monitoring and interactions
with
non-humans like the tall whites and the
tall nordics
without the world being concerned that
there could be a threat from some other
direction
and he spoke just like that to me in
2014.
over the last three or four years
i have heard similar statements from
people who work in aerospace as
engineers
people who are working in biological
sciences
people who are
working on
what would essentially be the
how are we going to open up the
alcubierre warp drive
to the planet as a technology that would
get us point to point in the universe
before we've
even introduced the non-humans who have
helped us get that technology
and you begin to realize that it is very
complex when you have an entire planet
that has been kept in the dark on
purpose for centuries
that the uncorking of the truth
that governments and intel have had a
lot of information developed since world
war ii
and when it comes to how do you open up
the truth if you compartmentalize the
truth and you leave out that there may
be a threat
in the end you still have another
problem
so i understand that what is occurring
they're trying to get all of these
various pieces now
in place
so that it could be a discovery through
something like the web which then it's
it's far away
and then eventually they will be opening
up all of these facets that they have
had since world war ii
and learning more and more about
um so
essentially
i don't know if you could say that the
cia which was formed in 1947 at the same
time as majestic 12.
did they have
a control reason
that was just because they wanted the
cia and then eventually the nsa and the
dia and all
that have been have evolved 1718 intel
agencies
did they want the control
because
they wanted to make sure
how it would be introduced to the world
to keep everybody calm
in that regard
it may be
that government denials for decades is
because they did want to help
humanity get to a point where they could
hear the whole truth
there are as many arguments on the other
side
that it has been
corporations
government heads and power brokers
of earth
who have wanted to keep the power that
they have in the knowledge of
extraterrestrial biological entities to
them
if you keep that kind of information
bottled up
to a small minority
they have the most power because they
have the secret knowledge
i think both
have been going on
and that we are finally in 2022 out of a
huge horrible pandemic
that it is beginning to be really clear
that they can't keep this secret much
longer they have got to open up the
truth
that we are not alone in this universe
and that why we homo sapiens sapien
exist
is because of genetic manipulation on
this planet
by many different species for many
different reasons
but for us to be kept dumb and blind
for another century
would be such an abuse
that i think that the tall nordics and
the tall whites are convinced
humanity needs to be told the truth
and if they are told the truth with
allyship
that could handle a threat
we will grow up fast
but at least
the earth would get out of this
straitjacket
of denials and lies
that we are alone in this universe that
has at least three trillion galaxies
okay this question is related to that
this one comes from jesus barabbi
linda and kurt i love what you're doing
please ask a question that pertains to
skinwalker ranch and if known how many
different alien species there are
potentially
you mentioned the
tall blondes the half whites
uh i have been told that there are at
least 168 different civilizations uh in
our milky way galaxy
and there are 3 trillion galaxies so you
might take 168 and multiply it times 3
trillion to get the estimated number of
civilizations in this particular
universe
the
issue of
i just had a thought explosion sure
start to give that question to me again
yeah yeah no problem
so
please ask ask a question that pertains
to skinwalker ranch and if it's known oh
yeah how many species there are
potentially and also just my sub
question if you can hold this in your
mind i'm curious
are there competing
hmm are there competing motivations
between the different aliens so that is
and i also don't like to use the word
alien but just just
for lack of a better word are there
different
reasons for certain ones interacting
certain ones not are some of them in
favor of mankind and others don't like
those who are in favor of mankind etc
i have no personal knowledge whatsoever
as an investigative reporter and a
producer writer director editor about
motivations of other intelligences in
this universe the only thing that i know
is
somebody is doing the bloodless
trackless animal mutilations something
is doing the abductions of humans and
have been doing it since at least the
early 1960s and both of those
military people testify about their own
interactions with ufos on the ground in
the air
that there are dozens and dozens of
first-hand testimonies about the
intrusions of e.t
type craft where we have minuteman
missiles and nuclear
nuclear sites underground
so it is a
huge number of different facets
of whistleblowers and testimonies that
we
now come to in 2022
that
there's no doubt from people who have
any education whatsoever
about what is happening between
non-humans on this planet and a variety
of phenomena that we are not alone in
this universe
and once you are there we're not alone
and there is a lot of testimony about
the types of civilizations that exist
between here and out 12 light years 20
light years and so forth
when you hear
on tv or in news that there is a ranch
like the skinwalker ranch in utah i've
been there
and that people who have lived in a
ranch house
have seen orbs like the size of
ping-pong balls come in through the
walls
orbs that float around in the house
animal mutilations strange
shape-shifting
animals all sorts of strange things
you realize that where the introduction
to most people on the planet has always
been
in kinds of phenomena that are spooky
and
scary
and that may or may not be
a legitimate tool
for
why our government and other governments
have decided that they will just allow
the spooky nature of something like
skinwalker ranch
to be a
self-perpetuating story
because in a way it it deflects from
people knowing anything about what's
actually happening with the phenomena
with the technology
mutilations abductions except in this
one place
so i have always thought of skinwalker
ranch as being
one of those where it focuses down
and therefore it seems it's manageable
it's on a ranch it's been there for
centuries
uh when you read about what the navajo
and the utes reported 300 years ago
300 years ago
in journals and things that have been
passed down and then have been repeated
the youths in the navajos always
considered the uinta basin which is
where the skinwalker ranch is
to be a place of what shapeshifters
the whole issue of skin walker that is a
native american name that goes back
to
300 200 years in navajo and youth
stories
what would the shape-shifting be
from 200 300 years ago up to 2022.
when you jump over to the human
abduction syndrome
there are hundreds of stories of people
seeing
something that look like one thing in
front of them and it morphs into
something else
um a lot of descriptions by people in
the abduction i could see i was standing
on my bed and i could see through this
reptilian next to my bed i could see the
dresser
through the being and then i knew
whatever i'm dealing with it's not flesh
and blood it is a projection like a
hologram
same type of issue at the skinwalker
ranch
projections
lights that might have been like a
hologram as well
so
whether it's the government
whether it's the non-humans
the
the entire slice of human witnesses
that have reported all of these uh
complex phenomena for so long
the utes in the navajo going back 200
300 years
it is as if there have been locations on
this planet where non-humans have based
themselves
and where the bases are are where there
are chronic centuries of phenomena
and i think that that is a true
assessment today of planet earth in 2022
that there are areas where there are
non-humans based underground
under oceans on this planet
and
those can be areas where there have been
phenomena
and then there can be other areas where
there's no phenomena and there's no
bases that is another i think
calculation by the governments
they know where there are non-humans
that are based on the planet and out
into the solar system
and as long as
they
know that the general population is not
living and being uh exposed to things
like skinwalker ranch
they can get away
with not
explaining anything
but
what i'm seeing between skinwalker ranch
ancient aliens that i've been in for the
last 15 years
is that the tv programs that began to
develop my own work
there are so many people now
the population of people who have had
interactions with non-human beings is
really large on this planet
and people have not felt comfortable in
the past to ever talk about it
gnomes fairies probably all of it was
the same phenomenon
now the population
the percentages
of people listening to any given
uh whether it's a broadcast or
whatever it is
they've had their own experiences and
they are the people that are coming
forward
to now for the first time in their lives
speak about what they have experienced
and it is happening
faster and more than i have ever seen
before it is like an inertial force that
is beginning to come from humans living
on the earth
that is the kind of energy
that i'm hoping that our government and
other governments
are finally going to look at all of this
and say
it is way past time there's so many
humans who are having experiences and we
now need to fill in the gaps
and tell the truth and they can say it
with an apology
we are sorry we didn't tell you before
but it has taken us this long to
understand how complex it is
and then
how many civilizations do we know about
that's where i think this is headed
and that the webb telescope will be part
of it
and that hard data hard physical data
hard images
will be how
they will announce we're not alone in
this universe
and then maybe we'll be back on a
healthy planet certainly healthier than
one that has denied
for centuries
what is now a clear truth we're not
alone in this universe
do you see there being a connection
between ufos and bigfoot slash orbs orb
seems intimately tied to the ufo
experience what about bigfoot
in uh my two volume glimpses of other
excuse me in my two volume uh glimpses
of other realities books
i have a a fascinating chapter with a
man who got a hold of me living up in
snohomish washington and snohomish is
one of those areas where if somebody
said where have you had the most bigfoot
sasquatch
ufos animal mutilations half cats
everything snohomish is one of those
areas what's a half cat
it's a variation on mutilations where
the mutilations are an ear eye jaw there
are half cats and there's no blood and
no tracks and a lot of habcats in
snohomish area
and uh i was uh
working in the 1990s on the two volume
when i got this first a letter and then
was able to talk with him on the phone
and
he did illustrations
uh he was
on a
quite a remote everything in snohomish
is quite remote and he and his dad lived
in a kind of cabin house and his father
had asked him to go down and pull weeds
in a garden
and that's what he was doing just
pulling weeds when he hears a buzzing
sound first and a lot of people say that
it sounded like a
thousand bees
that's the first thing they hear in the
sky
and then these were tall ponderosa trees
the ponderosas start moving there's no
breeze
he is in complete still air but the
trees start doing this moving as if
there's wind but he's not feeling any
wind yeah but there's no wind with the
trees and then the buzzing and the trees
moving because he's turned to watch in
fascination
here comes this silver disc
clear as can be
settles down right above where the trees
are going back and forth
then he sees
what looked like two as he called them
like air columns
i could see that they were columns that
came down from the the disc
uh as if they were air in air no color
in other words he could just see
cylinders but it was like the air had
made these
and then
two beings one in this column and one in
this column in sparkly leotard type
suits
come down
and he's still standing exactly where he
had been weeding
and he watches them come out of these
columns pay no attention to him
and they start walking in a path
and he is
should i
go after them
i i don't know what to do i feel afraid
and then he said
he heard a noise and he looked up
and coming down now in another one of
these air tubes it looked like a gorilla
comes down
this air opens up as he says it's a what
he called a sasquatch and now he is
terrified he said i i think i stopped
breathing i stopped moving i don't know
what's going to happen but he said this
sasquatch went right off behind those
two beings
that was
the story that he came to me about what
happened
then i was able to talk with the deputy
sheriff who went out to investigate
and the deputy sheriff said
the path
where he had watched those beings
the deputy made plaster paris of 17-inch
long feet
which our photograph is in my book
and that
at that period of time from from that
point of going out to this farm
they had mutilations they had sasquatch
reports they had people calling the
sheriff's office saying they were
hearing this high-pitched loopy sound
that is associated with similar buzzing
or that's different
the buzzing is different
the eye looping voice is what has been
recorded by many people as associated
with the sasquatch recorded and
oh yeah
i have used recordings of sasquatch from
sohomish going all the way back to the
early 90s linda have you ever tried ce5
ce5 steven grier ce5
no i don't really so okay have you ever
tried any technique to induce
contact
no
have you had any experience with
craft on your own either when well
perhaps investigating
the one unusual sky object that i have
seen was in
aurora colorado
um it was a documentary project
and
i was in denver colorado and i had been
asked to go to a meeting with people
about a new documentary in a bank
and the meeting broke up at around six
o'clock
and i'm coming out of one side of the
bank everybody else went the other had
two
entrance exits so i'm alone coming out
of the meeting
and when i uh came through the door and
started down the stairs
i was looking at a beautiful slivered
moon and thinking how beautiful the sky
was
walking toward my car
with a briefcase on my right shoulder
and something that i'll never understand
made me spin
when i got near a car so hard that my
briefcase hit the car and i'm looking up
and there was this huge huge boomerang
shaped craft
and it had it did not have lights on it
but whatever it was made of which was
sort of like a grayish brown it seemed
metallic
it looked like that there were floors
and levels in in the front of it
and it tapered
and i
not a sound
and i stood there watching this move
without a sound
but knowing that this is exactly
the kind of phenomena that had been
being reported in new york state
a book was written about it and jay
allen heineck had done the forward
having to do with boomerangs
that moved slowly that had no sound in
new york
while i'm in colorado and this was in
1986.
so i had done uh the animal mutilation
broadcast was in 1980
may 25th 1980 was when a strange harvest
was first broadcast
so by 1986 i had been investigating
animal mutilations human abductions and
all in my tv work
and
had heard people describe
something like this but it is the one
and only time in my life where i saw
something that made no sound
i have no idea but it matched what was
being described in another part of the
united states
man your memory recall is great for
dates and so on
holy moly i've had a fly paper mine
we were talking just the audience we
were talking off air about how linda
feels
as energetic if not more energetic than
she's felt at her maximum so that's
great
yeah
okay actually someone has a question
about that brandon detroit fan said
she'll be 80 in a couple weeks and looks
amazing can you ask her if alien
technology is keeping her looking so
great
well my 80th revolution around the sun
was celebrated yesterday january 20th
with my brother in santa fe we had a
wonderful time
and
the number eight zero
doesn't have a meaning to me because i
have never felt stronger or more
energized to keep doing the work that i
have been doing for 42 years trying to
get to the bottom of the ufo animal
mutilation human abduction government
cover-up we're not alone in the universe
story
and
for the first time i feel like
that the timeline that we're on
has to inevitably now open up
to
finally a whole global uh power broker
leadership admission we're not alone
and that
the pandemic
the coveted pandemic has changed so much
about the world
and now i think we're going to have
another revolution which will be we're
not alone in the universe and we will
finally be
introduced at least to some of the
information that our government has
about different types
and where they are
and what they know and that we have
allies and there may be a threat but
that the allies are prepared to protect
and help us
and that may be
the
way that they get this
introduced to the public
because
everything is not simple everything is
not
light
there's a lot of complexities
and i think that's what's been holding
the government back
and now going through two years and a
pandemic that's been so horrible
it's almost like
that
a new
future
is opening up and part of that future
has got to be telling us the truth about
other life in the
universe caleb peters on that note
actually and just i should say that
chichu 98 had a question about the
stephen greer and aliens via meditation
consciousness i asked that before but i
just want to give credit to chichu 98
because he had a similar question he or
she okay caleb peters wants to know what
does linda think about the recent
pentagon uap footage is the government
slowly releasing information to prepare
us
i think a decision was made somewhere uh
about
two to three years ago
that they had to start introducing
pieces
that could still be argued about
but that our government knew were
legitimate craft
and that that's where the navy of videos
and what we have been shown piece by
piece by piece
they have so they don't want
incontrovertible evidence because then
people would say oh aliens exist for
sure and they're trying to prepare us
slowly
yeah i think so i think that
the tic tac and the laying out of some
of these videos that
they the government knows
that they are showing legitimate ufo
from some other place meaning another
intelligence they know that
but the way it's been presented to us
over since 20 2018
is
still that scientists can argue about
what it is or what it means
they have not put those films out and
said this is extraterrestrial biological
entity technology and we know the beings
come from serious a
or some statement like that
which
that's when it will be real
kurt wouldn't that will you say it won't
be real until the our government and
other governments
are making those kinds of sentences
this is film that we know is this craft
from these beings
that live in this part of our milky way
galaxy
once that begins to happen which is
what i hope will still occur in the next
year or two
then it becomes real otherwise it's
exactly it's more of a deflection here
is
film
and
luge
lou elizondo
has made excellent points
about the fact that some of these
infrared or radar are an object that's
going 12 000 miles an hour and stops on
a dime
and there's no human technology that can
do that
there no human could survive the
inertial forces of 12 000 miles an hour
in stopping
so that is in of itself you would think
enough
evidentiary material that it would go
the next step and physicists would say
well that doesn't happen so we have to
be dealing with something that is not
human
and yet we're still
tiptoeing up
to that
rat x 172 wants to know
is there evidence that timelines can be
manipulated
i am told that timeline manipulation is
one of the non-human technologies
but
what would be evidence to a human
that there was timeline manipulation
beyond what people in the uh abductions
have been reporting for decades
that they saw uh that it was 11 p.m
and then
they don't know what happens but the
next time they look at the clock it is 4
00 am and they know something happened
but they they call it missing time
so
it seems to me that the abductions going
all the way back into the 50s
and the certainly the early 60s they
always had this component of missing
time
and missing time by definition is
manipulation of time
or certainly manipulation of the human
mind
which loses what happens between 11 pm
and 4 a.m
see the way i interpreted that question
was not about
because we have that experience when
we're standing in line sometimes time
passes or when we're driving i'm
thinking more about some of the theories
around
what aliens are
is that they're a future human race and
they're coming back in time
so i'm thinking more in terms of time
travel and we ordinarily think of time
as having one dimension well what would
it mean if it has multiple dimensions so
i'm thinking in terms of that have you
seen heard of evidence regarding that
the aerospace engineers and the
scientists that i've talked to in the
last 10 years
about
what they call manipulation of time
technology
has to do with how the advanced
civilizations
can literally manipulate timelines to
their advantage
something that i think is almost
incomprehensible to the human mind
we live in a timeline that we have no
influence on
and yet we are dealing with other
intelligences that appear to use
manipulation of time
in order to
abduct us
in order to accomplish
whatever their work is and the only
residue that humans end up with is
it was eleven o'clock
and when they become conscious again
it's four am
so the idea that we are dealing with
intelligences that would be us from the
future
i personally don't think
that that is
uh obvious to me
as much as that there are other
intelligences from other solar systems
that have had involvement with our
planet
as the dia guy told me in 1999
for at least 270 million years
that there have been conflicts
tremendous amounts of genetic
manipulation on our planet
by extraterrestrial biological entities
and we are one of the products
so that chromanian homo sapien sapien is
the latest example of what ets
manipulated in dna to create and
neanderthalensis would have been another
standing up humanoid before us
and that leaves then the mysterious
question
this leaves the question
why was there a cross fade
from neanderthal
to kromanian 45 000 years ago
the neanderthals had even a larger brain
capacity
than what came in the kromanian homo
sapien sapiens skull
so
they were big
they know from anthropology and
archaeology
investigations that the neanderthals
put flowers on the graves of their dead
that means that they had a spiritual
component
what was the reason that kromanian homo
sapien sapien current humanity
replaced neanderthal
i don't know
well those are the questions that you
run into when you're talking with people
coming at this from a long career of
scientific investigations these are the
kinds of questions they have
there's this question that keeps coming
up over and over so i can't say the
specific username because there are many
usernames so one is mark medwed and
another is
well
it's just what's the latest in
antarctica
before 2018
[Music]
i had talked with a whistleblower at a
conference
conferences
before covid were one of the best ways
to have people who had served in
military or intelligence
they can approach you in a crowd you're
covered by noise
and i have found that to be one of the
more successful moments where you will
get information and usually it's
verifiable later
so i'm in a conference and
a man approached me and he said
you really need to know that
in antarctica
there is
some kind of a huge gigantic base it's
been there for maybe millions of years
and it is
uh in the category of being an
extraterrestrial creation it's not from
humans
and he said and i have
a friend
who is a navy seal
and you need to hear from him firsthand
about what he has seen
on a mission there
that's how it starts is this spartan one
and two
okay yeah so
so within uh
about two or three months after that
discussion at that conference
i got letters
i got documents
dd24
14 forms that all people who have served
in the military in the united states
must have
on the backgrounds of these individuals
and
we were working through mail
as opposed to the phone
and i proposed in mail a place
that i could meet them
and that i would
be able to record them
about what they knew about
a base in antarctica
and
in the late summer of 2018
i was able to
make that meeting
and the
marine
spartan ii and the navy seal spartan1
came
and for uh two days
with me running camera
audio
setup
we
talked through what they knew firsthand
and it was under the condition that i
would voice alter
and keep them in silhouette
and
[Music]
after
i released my documentary
antarctica alien secrets beneath the ice
at the end of 2018 and into january of
2019.
i got another contact
from a person in new mexico who says you
need to meet
he's been
to this base that you're talking about
in this documentary with spartan 1 and 2
three
times and so i had another meeting
but not
he would not allow it to be recorded
so i got to hear from yet another navy
seal
who saw my work and was provoked
and what he added
was
three times in an even
bigger scientific context
that we were able to
find through deep ground penetrating
radar
evidence and have that evidence of this
huge underground installation which is
how
the seals came to go down there
they did missions specific missions
and
they both knew
that the walls were some kind of basalt
and that there was language that was
equally they measured it with laser
measurements
every single symbol thousands of them
was exactly
two point
one four or three four i don't remember
exactly the decimal
that the symbols as if they had been
created all at once
at exactly the same depth over all of
the walls in this big installation deep
underground
and
the to have the first two and then have
another navy seal be able to take me
further with more details
has strengthened uh
what i think
isn't going to be another one of those
someday we will be told
that there is a huge installation two
miles
the all three men said that it was at
least two miles
under ice and that the closest place
that we would know
would be beard more glacier
and beardmore glacier
is famous with a c-130 crew
that had been flying in the 1990s in
antarctica for several months on
missions and they would see silver
discs
come up out of the beard more
edge not over the glacier but on the
edge
and that they had discussions as crews
why do these silver things come up and
they never cross over the beard more
glacier
so that had been another
part of why the navy was interested
what are these silver craft
that are coming
outside of beardmore glacier but in that
general area
so i have had several different facets
from several different people but the
strongest being
sparta 1 and spartan 2 for my film
do you believe those crafts or crafts
that uap phenomenon in general is
physical this comes from kinger90210
because bigelow and his institute the
bigelow institute
and others are slowly coming to the
conclusion that this is more of a
consciousness phenomenon
it's both
it's consciousness the universe is
conscious
interacting with brains i interviewed
roger penrose about this very issue back
in 2018.
and he and stuart hameroff
down in arizona they have
had hypothesized that we have brain
tubules that have been just discovered
in 2014
and their speculation as scientists was
that
the universe
has consciousness that can interact with
other conscious life forms
and that this is a very important part
of
humanity's future if we will just be
taught and educated about this
and
that
consciousness means
that you might be able to concentrate on
light
and affect the frequency of your mind
and your soul and your body
to create a relationship between a
conscious universe and consciousness
but that doesn't mean that the universe
that is conscious as
roger penrose would say
and the brains that are in it
it doesn't mean that everything
uh
is in a state of
just energy vibrating
matter this is a matter universe
matter beings
matter craft
both are
present when you get into these
discussions about advanced intelligences
they're coming in physical craft they
are matter craft
but they have the ability to
surf gravity waves
to
bend time as it's called like the
alcubierre warp drive and move point to
point
and i have heard about that point to
point
travel
since i did a strange harvest in denver
back in 1979 i met a physicist who told
me they even then that they knew about
ufos and ets that could move point to
point
so
matter and matter craft
that can perform
going from one point to another point
in seconds minutes days
that doesn't mean
that it is not a matter universe it
means that there are different
abilities
the more you
evolve in your uh
in your ability to work in the universe
that we're in
and that is what the famous space
tunnels that are being described for the
very first time in a lot of literature
is about
the space tunnels are how the non-humans
move around
and that is again coming back to the
alcubierre warp drive
we haven't been introduced to any of
this
as a world civilization of humans this
is coming through people who are
physicists
uh who may be investigating what's going
on with ufos
but we're still in a segmented
fragmented world when it comes to any of
this information
leaks
give you hints what we need is the whole
truth and
the big picture about who is interacting
with us our planet why
and how
many of our own military forces as i've
been told
have been going out to other solar
systems since at least 1972
and the disconnect between what humans
may already be existing in other solar
systems in a military way
versus a planet that still has not even
been told the truth
that disconnect i think it has to end
so this question comes from
travis roberts at nm underscore uap
i have seen some interviews broach the
dodi benowitz issue with linda but it
doesn't seem to go well
much of linda's information can be
traced back can be traced back to miss
to mister disinformation himself i just
want to know her relationship with him
you're talking about
april 9th
1983
uh kirtland air force base in
albuquerque
this was a meeting set up for me by
peter gersten the attorney who
filed foia the first foia
freedom
freedom of information act requests
for citizens against ufo secrecy
and
his name was peter gersten
let's i'll go back to get to the
timeline
in
march
of
1983
i was in new york city at home box
office signing a contract with home box
office to produce an hour film for hbo
they already had the working title ufos
the e.t factor
i had the meeting that afternoon with
executives at hbo and the head of
the documentary unit i had already
provided them a script outline of what i
wanted to do in ufos the e.t factor and
everybody was extremely excited about
doing this film
that night
i knew peter gerson and patrick quage
peter gersten had represented citizens
against ufo secrecy
in the very first freedom of information
act filings as an attorney that led up
to a supreme court
session
in which
the he had
he peter
had filed against all known
intel agencies
for information about ufos and what they
were and represented and it finally
there was a headline in january of 1980
about this and the fact that when in
an in-camera session took place
uh with peter gersten there as an
attorney representing citizens against
ufo secrecy
the only
thing that was allowed
were pages all blocked out
stanton friedman would use those
pages blacked out for years after in his
conferences that this is what the
government
said to peter gersten on freedom of
information act request about what do
you know about ufos and et's
so that is the person peter gerson that
i met with after my hbo contract signing
that night
and he and peter wage and i
uh sat around on a small table where
peter
had a briefcase and he started bringing
out documents
handwritten letters
typed letters
of a person
richard c doty
on the documents on the letters who
worked at kirtland air force base
in afosi air force office of special
investigations
peter gerson is showing me linda howe
the producer now with the new contract
for hbo
look at what he is saying in these
letters
and the letters were about the exchange
of a some kind of a laser what looked
like a laser beam
at ellsworth air force base
in which they had eyewitness military
that a silver disk landed
an opening came on the side
a security guard drew his weapon
an opening came in the ufo
a blonde being perhaps
came out
the
security guard
pulled the trigger
or was about to pull the trigger
and and what looked like a laser beam
hit the security guard's hand holding
the gun
his skin
was burned surface burned
but one of the amazing things to our
government was
what is that weapon because we want it
he dropped the gun but it did not
destroy the hand
with surface burns this is what peter
presented to me with at that dinner that
night in new york he said we want to
investigate this
and that this
afosi agent in albuquerque new mexico
has information
and we want to set up a meeting
you go talk to him about the ellsworth
air force base we want to investigate as
citizens against ufo secrecy
and you can cover it as a segment in hbo
two weeks later
peter gerson calls
says here's the phone number
uh he says he can meet with you on april
9th
call and confirm
so when i flew down to albuquerque
to have the meeting it was set up by
peter gersten the attorney
what i was supposed to be given
information about i was told
is
the ellsworth case
when
i am taken into the afosi office through
all these punch locks where they have to
punch buttons to get through doors and
we went into
a big office he said my boss said to use
his office
and we go into this office and as we are
they were two stairs down from the door
to where the actual desks in the office
were
he said
you broadsided the united states
government with that film you did
and i
i'm thinking peter gersten and ellsworth
what are you talking about he said your
documentary is strange harvest
we never thought
that any credible professional
journalist would touch that with a 100
foot pole
that's how that started
that's exactly where it started
and he sat down behind the desk and
motioned to a chair
and
i think that i am there
to get the names of witnesses to the
laser shooting at ellsworth air force
base that peter gerson and i would work
on as a segment for hbo
and when i asked him if he had the
witness names because that's what peter
said to ask for
he said
that's really not as important
as my superior officers i think is the
way he put it or my superiors
have asked me to show you this and he
reached into a drawer and pulled out of
that kind of shape
envelope
and reached in
and pulled out
maybe 12 pages
and he said
you can read this
but you cannot take notes
and i want you to move from the chair
you're in to that chair and there was a
large chair in the middle of this large
office
later on i would learn that that chair
was what was used to videotape people
who were brought to that office but
right then
everything is changing because i think
i am supposed to get the witness names
of ellsworth
and leave
i had another meeting scheduled with
other people in new mexico
but now i have in front of me on the top
page all caps
briefing paper for the president of the
united states of america on the subject
of unidentified aerial craft
the briefing paper did not use ufo uap
it was uac
and
unidentified area vehicles uavs uavs and
uacs
the first page
was the typical robinson panel sign
grudge
mantel the airplane that was exploded by
a ufo all
coming into the first page the second
page i'm reading history
and then somewhere around the third page
in the middle
it came down to
a subject
about in the past in the ancient past
and it said
these extraterrestrial biological
entities
manipulated dna in already evolving
primates to create homo sapiens and the
latin homo sapien was there
and then it went on for two or three
more sentences
did it happen to give a timeline of
no
no
and then it went on for two or three
more sentences
and
at the end of this document tying to
that paragraph
was a
list of project names
and the top project all caps
project garnet
i made a note to myself
that remember your birthstone linda
remember your birthstone i'm born
january 20th
and the birthstone is garnet
so it said project garnet
all caps and this is exactly what it
said because i've never forgotten
all questions and mysteries
about the evolution of homo sapien on
this planet have been answered and this
project is closed
and i am a person
who i'm sitting there
because i thought i was doing a military
ellsworth
laser shootout
with a being at a silver disk
i'm being shown a briefing paper for the
president of the united states allegedly
that is talking about ancient history
and the manipulation of dna
in already evolving primates to create
humans
and that it is referenced twice in the
papers
from that day
forward
because
as a professional when i got back to
denver the first person i called was
gene abenader the director of uh hbo
documentary in new york
i explained
i came for a meeting about ellsworth
i have now been presented a paper that
seems to imply that the entire evolution
of humanity is related to genetic
manipulation by extraterrestrial
biological entities
she said
you must come back to new york for
another meeting
we must talk about this with bridget uh
potter and michael fuchs was the head of
hbo and bridget potter potter was second
in command
and
two weeks later
i'm in new york
i'm sitting in front of bridget potter i
explain everything i've just explained
to you
i have some materials
and
she said unless
you can bring to me
statements or the person who is
president of the united states the vice
president
the secretary of defense and the joint
chiefs of staff
i will not authorize funding for
continuation on this
documentary gene abinador
looked devastated the documentary crew
at hbo they
we had a script we'd already had
approval on the script
i have to if i'm going to work on any of
the material that richard dodie has
talked about that they may be able to
unfold
i had to talk with hbo but that's how
in within two weeks
signing a contract
april 9th going to kirtland set up by
peter gersten
and everything goes off on a completely
different track
and then
i had to decide
what am i going to do bridget potter
said if you can
bring back any of those people the
president the vice president the
secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and she seemed to be serious
if you can bring any of them to me
i will then reauthorize going forward on
this documentary
so
the
rest of 1980
to
in into that period of time 83
uh up to 80
the fall of 85
it was my money
my time
my development
and
[Music]
and then the
the contract ran out
in uh 1980 end of 1985
and by then i had decided that i was
going to
continue to try to do documentary work
in this field because
those sentences in that paper
having to do with
these extraterrestrial biological
entities manipulated dna and already
evolving primates to create homo sapien
that
i could never turn away from wanting to
know more
do they use the word biological to
describe the aliens
yes
yes extraterrestrial biological entities
are the three words that make up the
acronym that they have been using for
decades ebens
all caps e-b-e-n little s
ebens extraterrestrial
biological entities
some of the beings are extraterrestrial
biological entities many more than ebons
are the androids
the cyborgs
the robots that are made
today i can tell you that for sure
i know that we're dealing with
tremendous amounts of artificial
intelligence we're also dealing with
holograms
but i'm telling you what happened to
your question
in 1983
having signed a contract to do a
documentary for home box office and
exactly what happened
with peter gersten the attorney setting
up the meeting
at kirtland air force base for me to go
with one direction in the film to
ellsworth and
everything
being
everything being focused on this
document
and of course my discussion then was
we're talking about the creation of
of humans by extraterrestrials
do you feel that you were misinformed by
dodie
anybody who is an air force office
of special engag investigations agent
that is their job
counter intelligence is what they do
so yes or no
brad is giving me a signal that my mic
battery is going to die okay okay
so how about we wrap up with three more
questions does he have a time limit like
on the battery or does he just need to
switch it do you want to take a quick
break linda
do you want to take a bathroom break and
come back
well
i'd have to switch microphones
completely he's got to switch out the
microphones we can do that yeah why
don't we take a two minute break we can
use the washroom he can switch out the
microphones you can have some coffee
you can celebrate your birthday
well we're at 12 30 and we started at 10
that's two and a half hours we'll wrap
up shortly i just want to make sure that
i get to some of these burning what
about one question okay we've got one
question give me one more question and
then sure okay okay let's see this
question is a tough question you look
like a tough lady with your leather
jacket so this one comes from steve
kambian from
truth seekers
on your website there's a picture of a
genuine alien taken to the moon
and the image that you used was from a
2005 video game called area 51.
came being so steve kambian is referring
to himself in the third person came in
from truth seekers emailed you
as the proof that what you're selling
was from a video game and and then you
refused to change so okay so whatever
there's some accusations there do you
mind explaining to the audience what
that picture is about its provenance and
perhaps why you would not take it down
if someone showed you it was video game
art
are you talking what are you talking
about
okay i will show i can show the image
i don't have it printed here but i can
show you i can show the audience the
image at some point so are you so you're
on you don't know what is being referred
to here with the
video game cover art of area 51 and that
being used as a genuine image on your
website apparently i have no idea what
you're talking about
okay so let's choose different question
this one comes from the unidentified
celebrity review
at lou angeles has there ever been a
case that you had to redact because the
information was incorrect and if so
which case thank you so much huge linda
fan
kurt i don't know why you are reducing
the interview to this kind of
petty stuff at the end i really don't
i have been
working
as a professional journalist
since 1968
i started at knbc television
i went to abc in boston
i was hired to be director of special
projects at the cbs station in denver
i have corrected
a million scripts i have no idea
40 50 years how many scripts
information
that is just elementary to being a
professional journalist and i have a
tremendous number of awards that are
even in boxes 35 40 professional awards
as a journalist
why you would end up
with some kind of a stupid question like
this is beyond me
it's hostile kurt
why would you do this
it's from it's meaningless
what have you done that you've corrected
what i mean why are you playing now
we're going to trap linda in some if
this is ridiculous
i'm asking some of the most upvoted
questions so there's the sentiment in
the community that you're a great
investigative reporter especially your
early work and that toward the end of
the career perhaps
not as much due diligence in vetting
sources this is just a perception so
that's why people are upvoting it by
whom that's not my relationship with the
world
i'm just telling you
this is what many people have upvoted so
i'm asking the questions that people
are interested in knowing the answer to
you're accusing me
of being some gullible two-year-old
and i have just celebrated my 80th
revolution around the sun
i have produced literally
a few thousand reports at our files.com
many many many documentaries for
television broadcast
there is something about this kurt that
just feels
so
so unprofessional
so unfair
i i am doing hard investigation every
day and every week of my life on a
variety of topics
i ask even louis alessando i ask many
people similar questions about ndas and
is this piece of evidence proof is it
proof do you have a public
record of so and so it's not as if this
is such a strange question
oh you just said it's because you have a
reputation
essentially of being gullible
i argue with that from the face of how
much i have produced that is
between my books my documentaries the
3000 earth files reports and on and on
the 15 years of the work i've done with
ancient aliens
it's the opposite
i'm come to all the time because people
say you do the best most credible
journalism in the field that's what i
hear
okay
well
i'm glad that you hear that
it's great it's great to hear that i
hope i'm not trying to be accusatory i'm
simply trying to ask the question that
many people are
are wondering and that for whatever
reason other people aren't asking
so please i don't mean to to offend you
many people are asking what
okay so i'm just
every time i read you a question it's
either taken from twitter or the live
chat or
from
reddit or from some other places where
there are likes and upvotes and people's
comments on comments and so i'm looking
at okay what are the questions that
people want to know the answer to most
and i'm simply asking them
is that not fair
uh nothing about the last 20 minutes
have been fair
well
all right okay well we'll just end this
and i apologize that
that
that you felt like it was hostile
that was not my intent
uh
it has this out
i'm a professional
producer writer director editor
i have a tremendous number of awards
from my point of view i know how hard i
work for facts
and that i take on subjects that some
people won't touch
because they're afraid
that's my answer
thank you linda thank you so much for
coming on i appreciate it
all right i'll stick around and i'll
answer some audience questions if you
have any
all right well i didn't expect it to go
like that i feel bad i did not mean to
accost linda i didn't under i didn't
think that she would interpret those
questions as being
but it's great now i know now i
i understand so for the next time i'll
be more
hmm
well
i'll broach the subject differently
because
otherwise i can't just have a certain
subject for example what is the piece of
evidence for x y or z and then not ask
that question so the topic needs to be
broached i could have broached it
differently
mark says
you did nothing wrong she was defensive
i don't i don't know about that i'm sure
i've done plenty wrong i'll be watching
it and then i'll i'll make some notes
okay well everyone thank you so much i
appreciate you
coming out and watching this
just so you know okay so someone just
donated and asks
warhammer badly says were you satisfied
with her answers she was asked about ce5
in other interviews and gave different
answers were i satisfied well sometimes
the answers were quite lengthy and it
was difficult for me to see
where the answer was to the question
that i asked
however when i did hear an answer i was
satisfied though
satisfied is a strange word because i
have 40 questions that come from one
question
well i feel horrible about that
well
i ain't well man oh man
yeah well tonight will be an interesting
night
okay everyone thank you so much i
appreciate you coming out i should get
going
okay and just so you know i'll be
interviewing someone named salvador
peace in perhaps one or two weeks
and salvatore is a huge fan of someone
named stefan alexander he's a physicist
a string theorist in particular
and there's the previous interview the
one that's up recently on the channel
is with him and sal told me
how much he loves stefan alexander and
loves that interview we may
be referencing some of the equations
from that interview
i'll leave it here and in that interview
if you want you can watch it it's
extremely technical
if you want to prep for when we speak to
sal
and i would like to go through sal's
navy patents with a fine-tooth comb i
don't know if i can do that in
given the short time frame but i can
certainly try
matt shapiro said matt sapiro says kurt
you should feel bad that was pathetic
free juice says curtis mate
internet history
luke says you did nothing wrong don't
beat yourself up well it seems like it's
a mixture so we'll see we'll see i'll
learn from this hopefully i'll re-watch
it and make some notes
i feel embarrassed for myself to be
quite honest and i
i i'm holding back my own cringe toward
myself
okay anyway everyone thank you so much i
appreciate there's many many people many
people saying kurt we stand by you i
appreciate that thank you krusty
thank you dirt flyer thank you free
juice thank you
bert jan bolink there's so many people
thank you all
thank you greg o'brien for
moderating thank you
and
take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you